Obligations in a Free Society.
In a free society, an individual may choose his own destiny.
But despite endless options in a "free" society,...
...a person is not truly "free" to do anything he desires.
For example, society establishes laws that each citizen is obliged to obey under threat of punishment.
This is done to curtail actions by individuals...
...that reduce the quality of life for others.
Beyond laws upheld by governmental authority,...
...in a free society there is another layer of restraint, which is religion.
Each religion dictates rules that its followers are obliged to obey.
Then, of course, there are the unavoidable rules each of us must obey as we grow up...
...which are handed down to us by our parents.
Many times these rules are much harder to avoid than societal or religious law.
There are many other expectations that are placed on people as well...
...that are not laws, religious requirements, nor parental rules,...
...but are social customs which become habits without any thought.
All of these various obligations work toward a common theme,...
...the peaceful coexistence of individuals in a free society.